En février 1964
Les Beatles ont apporté l'optimisme en Amérique.
Seulement quatre mois plus tard
Les Rolling Stones sont arrivés.
Ils se sont fait une antithèse, vraiment,
de ce qu'étaient les Beatles en termes d'image.
Les Beatles voudront peut-être te tenir la main,
mais les Stones veulent
viens brûler ta ville.
Rebelle, dangereux, drogué,
sexy, c'est ça les Stones.
Mais comme la paix et
l'amour s'est répandu depuis la Californie,
Les pierres plus dures
la vision semblait déplacée.
Les pierres sont durcies.
Ils n'ont jamais complètement mordu
tout l'idéalisme des années 60.
"Nous pouvons transformer les choses en fumant du pot."
Ce n'était tout simplement pas réaliste.
Dans un sens, la vision des Stones était plus vraie.
Et puis, quelques mois après
L'été de l'amour,
le monde entier a changé.
En 68, l'obscurité qui était
associé aux pierres
définitivement en harmonie avec ce qui se passait
dans les rues de Chicago,
et Paris, et Londres.
Le sang coulait dans les rues.
Les températures étaient
monter, monter très vite.
C'était comme si c'était leur heure.
Ce film retrace
Les pierres à travers ça
époque turbulente, jusqu'à
le Festival d'Altamont en 1969,
le concert qui a amené
la décennie à une fin choquante.
Tout comme il y avait un élément de The Stones
qui aimait le chaos, et aimait
trouble, ils n'avaient aucune idée
dans quoi ils s'étaient embarqués à Altamont.
Cela ne s'est pas passé comme ça.
Vous verriez la vraie laideur,
sauvagerie sous vos yeux.
Les Hell's Angels étaient horribles.
C'est comme un accident de voiture.
Tu ne peux rien faire
à ce sujet, vous êtes juste dedans.
Les choses sont allées de mal en pis,
et il n'y a pas de contrôle.
C'était probablement, l'un des
pires jours de ma vie, jamais.
17 octobre 1969.
Après une pause prolongée
du spectacle vivant,
Les Rolling Stones touchés
à Los Angeles pour commencer
préparatifs pour le plus grand
tournée de concerts de leur carrière.
Devant jouer à 16 ans
arènes à travers le pays,
pour la jeunesse en plein essor
culture, le retour des Stones
sur la scène américaine
était très attendu.
C'était attendu comme un grand événement,
un grand événement, et on en attendait beaucoup.
Les gens voulaient entendre
ce que les Stones avaient à dire.
Les Rolling Stones n'avaient pas joué
en Amérique pendant trois ans environ.
Les choses avaient changé
radicalement au cours de ces trois années.
Quand les Rolling Stones
avant jouaient,
les filles mouilleraient littéralement
eux-mêmes et crier
la maison vers le bas, et le
le spectacle peut durer 20 minutes
avant tout 10 000 personnes se sont précipitées sur scène.
Alors les Rolling Stones étaient
confronté à quelque chose qui,
au début complètement
en quelque sorte les a effrayés.
Quel était le public qui
assis là et voulait écouter.
Annoncé comme
le plus grand groupe de rock and roll
dans le monde, malgré une
changement d'environnement,
Les performances phares des Stones
est devenu l'étoffe de la légende.
Tout le monde était en feu, tu aurais
puiser l'énergie d'un groupe,
et vous obtiendriez une énergie des fans.
J'aimerais le fait que je
pourrait aller les regarder
tous les soirs, et ce serait
être un peu différent à chaque fois.
Mais c'était super, le
les spectacles étaient spectaculaires.
Les garçons savaient jouer.
En 1969, les Stones étaient
incroyable, ils étaient brillants.
Je veux dire que ces émissions étaient bruyantes.
Les pierres étaient les plus grosses
groupe de rock and roll sur la route.
Les Beatles avaient tiré
dos, Dylan avait reculé.
Mais les Stones étaient là-bas en 1969.
Et venir en Amérique en 1969 n'était pas une blague.
Les pierres étaient dans
l'épaisseur de tout ce qui était
racket autour de l'Amérique à cette époque.
L'Amérique en 69 est dans un
état d'un certain tumulte.
Nous étions passés de
L'été de l'amour en 67.
De toute évidence, les choses sont devenues beaucoup plus sombres,
en partie à cause des manifestations de la guerre du Vietnam.
Nous avons eu l'assassinat
de Martin Luther King,
et Kennedy, donc il y a un
humeur beaucoup plus sombre à l'étranger.
Il y a toujours cet air de
l'optimisme hippie. '69 est,
à certains égards, le point culminant de cela,
plutôt que L'été de l'amour en 67,
parce que c'est l'été de Woodstock.
Tenu en août 1969,
avec près d'un demi-million de spectateurs,
le festival de Woodstock
C'était quatre jours mémorables
concert gratuit qui a tenu lieu de testament
à la force croissante
de la culture des jeunes.
En novembre, tard dans leur
tournée, les Stones ont annoncé
leur propre concert gratuit sur la côte ouest.
À l'origine se tiendra à San
le parc du Golden Gate de Francisco,
cet événement finirait par avoir lieu
sur un hippodrome éloigné appelé Altamont.
Altamont était destiné à
être une expression d'optimisme,
des forces de la contre-culture,
un événement auquel toutes les tribus
pourraient se réunir.
Ainsi, en surface,
lors de sa première annonce,
c'est une énorme nouvelle et
et c'est une nouvelle festive.
La mythologie des concerts gratuits était
à la hauteur absolue en 1969.
Toute la phrase gratuite
le concert sentait juste
avec toute cette éthique,
et des images et des idées
qui flottaient autour
la contre-culture de l'époque.
Ça aurait pu
fantastique, tout le monde supposait
qu'ils regardaient un mini Woodstock
dans le Golden Gate Park de San Francisco.
Ce n'est pas ce qu'il s'est avéré être.
L'événement lui-même
s'avérerait désastreux,
un point de bascule où
le rêve des contre-cultures
de solidarité pacifique
s'est tragiquement effondré.
Et la violence et le chaos que les Stones
s'est retrouvé nez à nez lors de ce concert
était bien loin du
Amérique apparemment calme
ils avaient d'abord rencontré
moins de 10 ans à l'avance.
Et le propre du groupe
développement au cours de cette décennie
entrelacé avec les courants changeants
de la culture de la jeunesse américaine
durant la même période.
Amérique, 1962, une nation
alimenté par une période
de la croissance politique de la prospérité.
La culture de consommation était florissante.
Progrès de la technologie
transformaient le quotidien.
Et beaucoup ont estimé que c'était
l'aube d'un nouvel âge d'or.
Le rêve américain
vivant et donnant des coups de pied une fois de plus.
Pourtant, une menace de guerre toujours présente
jeter une ombre sur cet esprit d'optimisme.
Et sous la surface confiante,
des tensions se développaient.
L'Amérique du début des années 60 est une
endroit étrange à bien des égards.
En termes de culture populaire,
c'est plutôt fade et anodin.
En même temps, politiquement, vous avez
Camelot et la cour de JFK.
Et il y a là un certain optimisme qui
nous avons rompu avec le
génération de l'immédiat après-guerre,
et c'est le début d'une vie plus jeune,
plus énergique, plus
une vie politique tournée vers l'avenir,
aigri dans une certaine mesure par la guerre froide,
aigri par la Baie des Cochons,
et la situation à Cuba.
Près de la moitié de la population de
les États-Unis ont moins de 25 ans.
Et il y avait ce sentiment d'héritage
monde qui avait beaucoup de problèmes.
Pour la jeune génération,
grandir avec la guerre froide
et la menace d'anéantissement nucléaire,
toute la prospérité matérielle du monde
n'allait pas vraiment à leurs préoccupations.
Des choses comme la communauté,
ou des choses comme la justice sociale,
ou la spiritualité, aucune de ces choses ne pourrait
être abordé par une économie rugissante elle-même.
Et en novembre 1963,
l'équilibre de la
nation a été brisée.
Le président John F.
Kennedy, pour beaucoup un symbole
d'optimisme et de rajeunissement,
a été assassiné à Dallas.
L'événement a stupéfié l'Amérique,
sa jeunesse particulièrement traumatisée
par la violence et le chaos
cela semblait représenter.
Mais au début de l'année suivante,
une voix d'espoir a émergé.
Et cela émanait de rivages lointains.
Les Beatles sont arrivés
dans quelques mois
de l'assassinat de Kennedy, alors ils ont marché
dans une nation qui était en deuil,
pleurer vraiment mal, et
était en état de choc.
Et ils sont apparus sur cet Ed Sullivan.
Et immédiatement ils ont mis
des sourires sur les visages des gens.
Ça sonne désinvolte et fade,
mais c'est vraiment ce qu'ils ont fait.
C'était de la médecine, ce que faisaient les Beatles.
Vous ne pouvez pas stresser assez
à quel point leur arrivée était importante.
Et le succès soudain aux États-Unis
de ce quatre pièces révolutionnaire
ouvert la porte à des dizaines
d'autres groupes britanniques à
essayer de briser l'Amérique.
Suite dans le
les pas des Liverpudliens,
Gerry et les stimulateurs cardiaques,
Les Chercheurs et Billy Kramer,
en juin 1964, un groupe londonien est arrivé
avec une image et un son très différents.
Contrairement à leurs compatriotes,
Les Rolling Stones n'étaient pas sur l'optimisme.
Il n'y avait pas le sens de
"le dernier groupe d'Angleterre."
C'était le truc, c'était
était l'invasion britannique.
Et chaque semaine c'était The Searchers,
et les Dave Clark Five,
et les ermites d'Herman,
et toutes ces affaires.
Les pierres étaient
quelque chose de totalement différent.
C'était juste complètement différent.
Personne d'autre n'essayait vraiment de faire quoi
Les Stones faisaient,
ils étaient dans le blues.
Ils étaient dans le noir
musique, et ils l'ont imitée.
Mais ils l'ont très bien imité,
et ils ont obtenu quelque chose de l'essence.
Ils ne jouaient pas seulement en surface.
Mais le
Stones', le chanteur Mick Jagger,
les guitaristes Keith Richards et Brian Jones,
le bassiste Bill Wyman et
le batteur Charlie Watts,
conclu que leur recours était limité.
Et leur première tournée américaine
avéré une déception.
Quand les Rolling Stones sont arrivés pour la première fois
aux États-Unis en 1964, ils n'étaient pas
accueilli avec un immense succès, au départ.
Leurs disques n'étaient pas encore passés à la radio,
et ils sont venus à Los
Angeles où ils sont apparus
dans une émission de télévision intitulée
Le Palais d'Hollywood.
Et l'hôte était Dean
Martin et il a dit, ces gars
vont rentrer dans les cheveux
concours de tirage avec les Beatles.
Ils jouaient avec deux éléphants,
quel genre de vous dit ce que l'Amérique
pensé aux Stones pour commencer.
Et Dean Martin, il a posé dans The Stones.
Eh bien, je vais vous confier quelque chose.
Vous connaissez ces signatures
les groupes sont aujourd'hui sous
l'impression qu'ils
avoir les cheveux longs.
C'est faux du tout, c'est une illusion d'optique.
Ils ont juste bas
fronts et sourcils hauts.
Ils avaient l'avancée
publicité, ils avaient les concerts,
mais l'Amérique n'a tout simplement pas vu dans
Les Rolling Stones ce qu'ils voulaient voir.
Ils voulaient vraiment un deuxième Beatles.
Et ce n'est pas ce qu'ils ont eu.
En revanche, leur montée
au sommet au Royaume-Uni avait été météorique.
Ne s'étant formé qu'au
l'été 1962, ils ont rapidement
se sont fait un nom
dans le circuit blues de Londres,
et est arrivé frais dans les Britanniques
graphiques moins d'un an plus tard.
Et où était l'Amérique
à la recherche d'un autre Beatles,
Les Stones plus tôt dans leur
la patrie avait été bâtie sur
les commercialisant comme le polaire
opposé aux Liverpudliens.
Leur manager, Andrew Loog Oldham,
soigneusement conçu cette image.
Ils ne souriraient pas sur les photos,
ils répondraient
indifféremment aux entretiens.
Dès le début, Le
Les pierres étaient présentées comme des rebelles.
Ils n'avaient pas tellement
un défi comme une insolence.
Il a mis les Rolling Stones sur
d'un côté, avec les jeunes.
Et il a mis l'établissement
d'un autre côté.
Ils étaient vraiment probablement les
premier groupe contestataire.
Il y avait une attitude punk,
sauf que nous ne l'avons pas appelé
punk à l'époque, nous
juste appelé ça loufoquerie,
ou loufoquerie, que
appliqué aussi aux Beatles,
et John Lennon en particulier peut-être.
Et tandis que Brian
L'instinct d'Epstein était alors
pour atténuer cela, mettez-les en costume,
et faites-les comme
respectable qu'il pouvait
sans perdre complètement leur avantage,
L'instinct d'Oldham était exactement le contraire.
Il avait certainement un
vision de créer un groupe,
un gang, c'était le
à l'opposé du gang des Beatles.
Je pense qu'ils ont compris la vision d'Andrew.
Et je pense que quand Andrew
dit ne souris pas, sois un peu maussade,
tu n'as pas à l'être, si Charlie ne le fait pas
veux répondre il ne répond pas.
S'il répond, il dit simplement oui ou non.
Et il est en quelque sorte monosyllabique et cool.
Que dirais-tu?
Pas dans cette première relation,
Il est trop tard pour s'améliorer.
Ce qui en est ressorti était un
haut degré d'individualité,
couplé avec le nous qui
Jagger avait depuis le tout début.
La fraîcheur que Keith
avait, et l'extraordinaire
charismatique Brian qui était
contrairement à ce moment précis,
contrairement à tout le monde que je pense que vous avez jamais vu.
Et l'image des pierres
complétaient parfaitement leur musique.
Après quelques mineurs
singles, leur tube de 1964
"Not Fade Away" a capturé le groupe
mélange unique de blues et de rock and roll.
Le son qui les avait fait
une sensation sur le circuit des clubs
les vit maintenant monter vers
le sommet des charts britanniques.
Les Stones ont vraiment été les premiers
des bandes R et B à émerger.
Je veux dire R et B à l'origine
est sorti du jazz
mouvement à Londres, les clubs de jazz.
Et c'était un peu mal vu,
c'était une scène un peu populiste.
Alors que le Mersey Beat
groupes, évidemment les Beatles,
mais ensuite vous avez eu Billy J Kramer,
tu avais Freddie et les Rêveurs,
étaient très axés sur la mélodie.
Mais les Stones avaient cette ambiance américaine sombre.
Ils n'ont pas regardé Mersey
côté, ils ont regardé à travers
aux États-Unis à Chicago
et les centres-villes.
Donc, c'était vraiment une nouvelle
son, il n'y avait vraiment rien
comme ce que faisaient les Stones.
La musique des Stones était vraiment une vigne.
Les crochets étaient tout au sujet
rythme, alors que je pense
les crochets pour les Beatles étaient
ouais ouais ouais et les harmonies.
Les Stones n'ont pas vraiment fait ça.
"Not Fade Away" a vraiment cristallisé cela.
Les Stones avaient ce côté blues R et B.
Et, bien sûr, dans Jagger, ils avaient ceci
leader charismatique, donc c'était plus terre à terre.
Le rock and roll avait en quelque sorte éradiqué c'est
origines noires, et a essayé de se faire
aussi blanc que cela puisse paraître.
Et, si vous voulez, les premiers Stones ont mis
le noir retourne dans la roche et
rouler, même s'ils étaient
garçons anglais blancs, de classe moyenne, de banlieue.
Après ça t'as eu la chaîne
d'événements que The Stones
étaient tout à coup bonne copie
dans les journaux nationaux,
c'est la version sombre des Beatles,
ils ne se lavent pas, tout ce genre de choses.
"Not Fade Away" est la chanson qui a fait ça.
Ils nous emmenaient
dans ce voyage rythmé,
et personne ne savait où cela allait finir.
En octobre 1964,
Les Stones se sont de nouveau rendus aux États-Unis.
Maintenant avec des singles à succès derrière eux,
et une notoriété grandissante
au sein du marché des jeunes,
cette fois, ils ont été invités à
La télévision d'Ed Sullivan
spectacle, qui avait contribué au lancement
les Beatles à l'échelle nationale
en début d'année.
Et le clivage générationnel
que le groupe avait ouvert
dans leur patrie, a été immédiatement
reproduits lorsqu'ils sont arrivés à l'écran.
L'apparition des Stones dans Ed Sullivan,
dans les journaux tout le monde
se plaignait de
parce que Mick Jagger a marché
sur scène en sweat-shirt.
Personne n'a fait ça dans The Ed Sullivan Show.
Jagger vient de s'en aller
scène comme s'il était dans un club.
La seconde que tu as vu
lui tu savais que c'était
franchir la ligne d'une manière scandaleuse.
Jagger chantait dans un
sorte d'accent noir américain.
C'était très sexuel.
Et à ce moment-là, le
Les Beatles étaient devenus en quelque sorte
une nouveauté pour les parents.
Vous avez tapoté sur le
tête pour aimer les Beatles.
Tu n'as pas été tapoté sur la tête
pour avoir aimé les Rolling Stones.
Les Américains plus âgés
a réagi avec un désarroi total,
sans comprendre pourquoi, bien que
instinctivement ils ont tout à fait raison
parce que les Britanniques étaient là pour remplacer
le show-business américain à l'ancienne,
et c'est exactement ce qu'ils
a fait, si longtemps Toady Fields.
Il présageait ce qui arrivait
être appelé le fossé des générations,
où la population adulte américaine est devenue
réellement menacé et
intimidés par leurs enfants.
Et ceux-ci
les enfants ont été impressionnés
par ce qu'ils ont vu sur Ed Sullivan.
Cette fois, avec la performance principale
le groupe directement dans
maisons à travers le pays,
Les pierres ont été instantanément élevées
au sommet du monde de la musique.
Et comme leur public
grandi, les indisciplinés aussi,
ambiance endiablée de leurs concerts.
Plus que n'importe lequel de leurs contemporains,
Les Rolling Stones ont inspiré le chaos.
Il y a eu beaucoup d'émeutes,
mais les émeutes étaient plus
Je pense que les fans essaient
pour se rapprocher de vous.
Mick le contrôlait habituellement,
et à la minute où tu as su
ils venaient
la scène, nous courrions vers
les vestiaires et verrouillez-les.
Il n'y avait pas autant
la sécurité mais les portes la gardaient dégagée,
aucun enfant ne poussait à ce moment-là.
Mais c'était effrayant.
Les Stones plaisaient beaucoup plus à
les garçons que les Beatles avaient fait.
Les Beatles ont encouragé les hurleurs.
Les Stones ont invité les garçons à participer.
Il y avait quelque chose d'un peu plus butch à propos de
Les Rolling Stones qu'il y avait
sur les Beatles, à cette époque.
Que ce soit le beat, le look rebelle,
les jeunes hommes se sont présentés aux concerts des Stones.
Sur le continent, pour
exemple Paris et la Hollande,
il y a eu de graves émeutes,
émeutes masculines, masculines, machistes.
C'était à nouveau comme du rock and roll,
défoncer les étals,
se battre avec la police.
Ce n'était pas seulement le fait que
c'était les garçons qui cherchaient un coup de poing,
c'était les médias, à un
dans une large mesure, qui s'est accumulé
les attentes du concert assez souvent.
Les gens de la sécurité juste
ne savait pas à quoi s'attendre.
Quand quelqu'un dit
toi que les Rolling Stones
viennent en ville,
il va y avoir une émeute.
Tu t'y prépares
éventualité au cas où.
La sécurité et le public
était un énorme problème,
ce que je veux dire finalement
vu que c'est le nadir à Altamont.
Mais ces poussées de désordre
n'a pas gâché l'ambiance
d'optimisme en Grande-Bretagne.
Vers la fin de 1964, une culture
et révolution artistique
était en cours, avec un
changement de direction politique
apportant un nouveau sens
de sens et de vitalité.
La jeunesse était au volant
siège, et la capitale nationale,
Londres, devenait un
foyer de créativité et d'innovation.
Après les Beatles, il
avait tous les yeux sur la Grande-Bretagne,
mais surtout tous les yeux sur Londres.
Du coup, les cinéastes, le monde de la mode
en particulier, gravitaient vers Londres,
et voir Londres comme une ville de culture.
C'était très très différent,
la vieille idée de la Grande-Bretagne comme
à l'ancienne, presque militariste,
établissement historique
symbolisé par la famille royale.
Nous avons des aristocrates maintenant,
et ils appartenaient aux ordres inférieurs.
Tu avais Julie Christie, Jagger,
Ringo Starr, Michael Caine, Terence Stamp.
C'était Londres en
1964, '65, c'était l'endroit
où tout le monde voulait graviter.
Et c'était l'endroit qui palpitait
plus que toute autre ville sur Terre.
En Amérique cependant,
les choses étaient très différentes.
Bien que l'arrivée des groupes britanniques
avait dynamisé la jeunesse du pays,
et révolutionné le
industrie du divertissement,
l'ombre de la violence
le conflit pesait lourd.
Au moment de la mort de John F. Kennedy
il y avait eu un certain nombre de
conseillers militaires au Vietnam
aider le gouvernement
dans le sud du pays
contre un communiste
insurrection du Nord.
Où Kennedy avait été
désireux de contenir cette implication
son successeur, le président
Lyndon Johnson, escalade
le conflit et engagé
forces américaines à une guerre terrestre.
En 1965, des milliers de jeunes
Les hommes américains étaient
appelé à l'armée
service et envoyé au Vietnam.
Et le président est immédiatement apparu comme
un ennemi de la culture croissante des jeunes.
L'histoire n'a pas favorisé une
système unique ou croyance,
à moins que la force ne soit utilisée pour le faire ainsi.
C'est pourquoi ça a été
nécessaire pour nous de défendre
ce principe de base de notre
politique, pour la défendre à Berlin,
et en Corée, et à Cuba,
et ce soir au Vietnam.
Le Vietnam l'a certainement fait
plus que tout au monde
politiser le fossé des générations.
Et la raison pour laquelle il l'a intensifié
quand il l'a fait, c'est qu'il a fait
la terrible erreur de
pensant que l'Asie du Sud-Est
était une rediffusion de l'Europe en
1938, et on nous a rappelé
maintes et maintes fois que nous
ne doit jamais faire l'erreur
de Munich réalisé par Neville Chamberlain.
Les deux choses avaient en fait
rien à voir l'un avec l'autre.
Mais malheureusement ils sont devenus une excuse
envoyer 500 000 Américains
soldats au Vietnam
dans une cause totalement désespérée.
Le projet qui a soutenu cette guerre
était incroyablement impopulaire, encore une fois,
90 millions d'Américains de moins de 25 ans,
beaucoup d'entre eux connaissent des gens
qui sont en cours de rédaction,
et servir, et mourir dans certains cas.
La guerre était donc extrêmement controversée.
Et il y a aussi un point important
auxquels les jeunes étaient plus attentifs.
Et c'était que le
explications sur la guerre,
ses origines et ses
développement, nous ne sommes pas véridiques.
C'est bien plus qu'une question politique.
C'est une question de confiance.
Et comme le
la guerre s'est rapidement intensifiée,
des manifestations ont éclaté dans tout le pays.
De jeunes Américains se sont joints à des militants pour la paix
organiser à grande échelle
manifestations et défilés.
Pendant ses études universitaires
institutions, les étudiants sont devenus
une voix puissante dans
la lutte contre la guerre.
Avec les jeunes maintenant activement
impliqué dans un conflit avec
une génération plus âgée qu'ils percevaient
comme de violents fauteurs de guerre,
la musique qui avait redynamisé leur vie
s'est engagé dans cette lutte.
Alors que les gens commençaient à protester contre la guerre,
et manifestations pour les droits civiques
avaient lieu,
rébellion dans le domaine culturel
commençait à prendre cette teinte.
Alors, ce qui semblait juste
comme les Rolling Stones
une sorte de hargne, tout à coup
avait un élément politique.
Le fossé des générations et
ne faites confiance à personne de plus de 30 ans,
et tout ce genre de
les idées se sont politisées,
pour que ce ne soit pas seulement le
genre de Marlon Brando
qu'est-ce que tu te rebelles
contre, qu'est-ce que tu as?
Eh bien, nous avons beaucoup, il y a
de quoi se rebeller.
Et à l'été 1965,
tout comme le président Johnson
a annoncé qu'il doublerait
le nombre de jeunes américains
appelé au service actif,
et alors que des émeutes raciales éclataient dans les Watts
quartier de Los
Angeles, les Rolling Stones
a publié "Je ne peux pas obtenir de satisfaction".
La chanson parfaitement captée
l'esprit de leur génération.
La "satisfaction" était vraiment
le record qu'ils ont en quelque sorte,
ils ne s'en sont pas rendu compte je pense, mais c'était
celui vers lequel ils travaillaient.
C'était celui qui
incarnait leur attitude.
Il incarnait la pulsion.
Et tu dois écouter
au rythme de ça.
C'était comme une marche, presque
un rythme martelant.
Et c'était la marche de la jeunesse,
la marche de la jeune génération.
Et puis tu ajoutes le
contenu lyrique en plus de cela.
Je ne peux pas obtenir aucune satisfaction, The Stones,
et ce disque en particulier était celui
à l'été 65 que
incarnait tout ce qui
les jeunes recherchaient en quelque sorte.
"Je ne peux pas obtenir de satisfaction" est devenu
une sorte d'hymne générationnel.
Et c'est une performance incroyable,
Je veux dire que c'est une ligne de guitare définitive.
Mais aussi la performance de Jagger,
au moment où il arrive à ce dernier couplet,
Je roule autour du monde.
Jagger est très sous-estimé en tant que chanteur.
Mais quand tu t'isoles
sa voix, et vous entendez
le genre d'engagement
qu'il apporte à sa livraison.
Il y a une raison pour laquelle à la seconde où tu entends
cette chanson tu ne l'oublie jamais.
Le sens du jeune
les gens ressentent ce genre de
mécontentement envers le courant dominant
culture, c'était beaucoup
dans les airs alors,
et ils lui ont donné voix.
Au cours de l'année prochaine,
Le son des Stones se développerait.
Et les célibataires qui suivent
La "satisfaction" a visé
sur le ventre sombre de la culture britannique.
Et en même temps en Amérique,
une nouvelle porte commençait,
celui qui aurait un
impact énorme sur les Stones,
et tous leurs contemporains.
Dans le lointain San Francisco
artistique, spirituel,
et la scène culturelle avait
en croissance depuis les années 1950.
Et son introduction de nouveaux
la musique, les drogues qui dilatent l'esprit,
et modes de vie alternatifs
était sur le point de changer le monde.
San Francisco a été une maison pour
les tragiquement mécontents
depuis le catholique
les missionnaires sont arrivés ici dans les années 1700.
Hospitalier aux radicaux,
rebelles, non-conformistes, il a attiré
ces sortes originales de
libres penseurs mécontents
des années 50, de l'après-guerre.
Et c'était de notoriété publique pour eux
que leurs parents ne les comprenaient pas.
Et l'un d'eux était un écrivain
du nom de Jack Kerouac
qui a construit un
livre épique, "Sur la route",
de deux juste comme ça
personnages en voyage
à travers le pays, et leur
destination est San Francisco.
Sur la route s'installa à San Francisco comme
la capitale de ce genre de pensée.
La principale chose qui a touché
de ce genre d'activité,
Je pense, c'est l'arrivée des beats,
l'arrivée de Jack
Kerouac et Allen Ginsberg.
Et puis en peu de temps vous avez
obtenu des chiffres comme Ken Kesey.
Une décennie
plus jeune que les beatwriters,
célèbre romancier,
Kesey a présenté la communauté bohème
à San Francisco à une nouvelle drogue, le LSD.
Et cela jouerait un rôle central dans
la scène culturelle qui s'est rapidement développée.
Ken Kesey avait gagné son argent en tant qu'auteur
de Vol au-dessus d'un nid de coucou.
Il avait été présenté
aux drogues hallucinogènes
par un gouvernement soutenu
programme d'essais expérimentaux.
Et puis il devient vraiment le lien entre
La Beat Generation d'Allen Ginsberg
et Lawrence Ferlinghetti, et l'émergence
mouvement hippie du milieu
années 1960, il est donc une figure charnière.
Il rassemble ce qui est venu
s'appeler les tests acides,
qui étaient multiculturels
événements, expériences,
à laquelle le LSD était généreusement
et librement diffusé,
et à laquelle le Reconnaissant
Dead est devenu le groupe house.
La pièce de théâtre Grateful Dead
là, ils font partie de
cette scène, le groupe house,
ce n'étaient pas vraiment des concerts.
Mais les Grateful Dead étaient là.
Parfois, ils n'ont même pas
jouer, ils étaient trop hauts pour jouer.
Et personne ne serait venu
là pour les écouter quand même.
Cela leur a donc donné une opportunité fantastique
développer sa musique dans
la manière qu'ils ont jugée appropriée.
Au début de 1966,
cette dérive musicale
des soirées LSD ont commencé
prendre de l'élan.
Aux côtés de The Grateful Dead, des groupes tels que
L'avion Jefferson et Big Brother
et la société holding
développé au niveau local
circuit club, créant des sons psychédéliques
qui a complété l'expérience de l'acide.
Dans les meilleurs clubs du Fillmore West,
et la salle de bal Avalon,
de ces expériences
une nouvelle culture musicale était
né, loin du contrôle
mains du commercial
industrie du divertissement.
Au Fillmore à Avalon
il n'y avait pas de projecteurs.
Il y avait un grand spectacle de lumière
qui couvrait le mur du fond
et la paroi latérale, et
n'était pas une science exacte.
Il couvrait des parties du sol
aussi, et les gens assis dessus.
C'était juste cet énorme ensemble de couleurs palpitantes
sortant de la lumière
projecteurs et boucles de films.
Et il n'y avait pas de projecteur,
il n'y avait pas de groupe à l'affiche,
et les étapes étaient très basses, genre 12,
18 pouces du sol,
et ces foules dansaient.
Ils ont dansé sur la musique, ils n'ont pas
asseyez-vous là et regardez comme un concert.
Et la culture
qui a commencé dans les clubs,
commença bientôt à se répandre
sortir dans les quartiers
et les espaces publics de la ville.
Avec son épicentre dans le
District de Haight Ashbury,
des concerts gratuits sont bientôt organisés,
avec The Grateful Dead
et d'autres groupes jouant devant de grandes foules,
à la fois dans les rues et dans les parcs locaux.
Fin 1966, le hippie
le mouvement était en plein essor.
Que se passe-t-il dans
San Francisco est animée par
un élan très démocratique,
mais ce n'est pas commercial.
Donc vous avez les concerts gratuits.
Je veux dire que les médicaments sont
aussi très très important.
Le LSD est encore légal en 1966, n'oubliez pas.
Et c'est un outil de libération,
et soudain la drogue
ne sont pas seulement sur
sortir de ta tête,
il s'agit d'élargir votre
tête, élargissant votre esprit.
Et ainsi de suite je pense
avec l'impulsion démocratique,
et l'amour, et la paix, et
ce genre de pseudo politique
notions philosophiques qui
sous-tendent le mouvement hippie.
Et tandis que la clé
notions d'amour et de paix
étaient au cœur de ce nouveau
contre-culture de San Francisco,
aux concerts gratuits un autre
groupe de non-conformistes
on les voyait souvent se frotter
épaules avec les hippies.
Les Hell's Angels, un
club de motards californien,
regardaient pareillement
vivre selon son propre code.
Une présence hors-la-loi dans tout l'État,
vu par les autorités
en tant que bande criminelle violente,
ils étaient entrés en contact avec Ken Kesey
et la contre-culture naissante
à un stade précoce.
Kesey a apprivoisé les Hell's Angels.
Il les a fait venir
La Honda, les a remplis de LSD,
et traîné avec les farceurs.
Et ils ont été apprivoisés par lui, ils l'aimaient,
ils aimaient le LSD, ils avaient tout ça.
Bientôt les Hell's Angels font leur entrée
aux concerts de Grateful Dead, et les gens
commencer à s'habituer à les voir.
Et en fait, ils peuvent être très utiles,
se reconnecter parfois
enfants perdus avec leurs parents.
Il n'était donc pas rare de voir
à certains de ces événements.
La contre-culture et
Les Hell's Angels étaient en quelque sorte
bons compagnons de lit parce que
sexe, drogue, rock'n'roll.
Vivre la vie rapide, vivre
vie en marge de la société.
Il y a une affiliation entre la rébellion
et des hommes à moto qui remonte tout de suite
à Marlon Brando dans "The Wild One".
Sur leurs vélos, ils exprimaient la liberté,
et de haut en bas le
autoroute, c'est sur la route,
sauf qu'ils sont sur leur
chevaux de fer, pour ainsi dire.
Mais je pense qu'il doit
ont été méfiants,
parce que les anges
vécu une sorte de vie différente.
Ils n'ont pas souscrit à l'amour et à la paix.
Pendant plus d'un
année cette nouvelle contre-culture,
cohabitant avec les anges,
avait pu grandir
organiquement avec peu d'attention médiatique.
Mais en janvier 1967, loin
plus grand concert gratuit a été organisé.
Connu sous le nom d'Humain
Be-In, il comportait des discours
de personnalités Timothée
Leary et Allen Ginsberg,
aux côtés de prestations musicales de
les principales nouvelles voix de la scène.
Le Human Be-In a été un énorme événement,
car c'était le premier du genre.
Vous n'aviez pas vu ce genre de foule immense
des personnes contre-culturelles
jusqu'au Human Be-In.
Donc, son exemple était extrêmement important.
C'était fait pour la télévision,
un peu comme un signal
aux médias nationaux
que quelque chose d'intéressant
se passe à San
La culture de la jeunesse de Francisco.
Les gens qui sont sur scène et qui parlent,
sont aussi faites pour la télévision.
Tu as Timothy Leary et Allen Ginsberg
dans ce genre de robes fluides,
Leary répand son message
sur les bienfaits des psychédéliques.
6 mots :
Allumer,
accorder,
abandonner.
Je ne pense pas que le mot ait fuité
beaucoup sur ce qui se passait
à San Francisco par
courant 1966.
Mais avec le Human Be-In en janvier 1967,
ça vient d'exploser
début de cette année-là.
Et la mythologie a été instantanée.
Harry Reasoner a montré
up, le journaliste de la télévision américaine
et cot, cot,
gloussé à propos des hippies.
Ils pensent qu'il y a une sorte de saint.
Et ce faisant, il
délivré un message codé
aux jeunes du monde entier
que ce n'était pas aussi répressif,
ce n'était pas aussi gris, qu'il y avait de l'espoir.
Et que tu pourrais aller à San Francisco,
faire pousser vos cheveux, et
les choses seraient différentes.
Tandis qu'à travers
Amérique, les jeunes ont afflué
au Haight Ashbury
Quartier en quête de cette utopie.
En Grande-Bretagne aussi, l'influence de
San Francisco s'est vite fait sentir.
Les idées contre-culturelles et
les modes ont traversé l'Atlantique,
lors de tournées de musiciens,
y compris les pierres
et les Beatles ont été introduits
aux hallucinogènes par
leurs homologues américains.
Parlez de la nouvelle drogue, le LSD
notamment fait craindre
cette culture populaire
devenait incontrôlable.
Où seulement deux ans à l'avance,
l'administration de
Premier ministre Harold Wilson
fêtait les Beatles et le boom
mouvement de jeunesse, maintenant un contrecoup a commencé.
Là où autrefois la clémence avait prévalu,
maintenant, un certain nombre de bustes de drogue ont été organisés.
Et en février 1967,
la police est arrivée en force
à la maison de Rolling
Le guitariste des Stones, Keith Richards.
Les stars de la pop avaient du soft power,
ils avaient un pouvoir culturel,
et ce qu'ils disaient
était de plus en plus désobéissant.
Mais bien sûr le
l'établissement n'aimait pas ça.
Et ils ont de plus en plus remarqué
des stars de la pop, et ce qu'ils disaient.
Et les Stones étaient vraiment idéaux
candidats alors pour des bustes de drogue.
Quand ils ont commencé à serrer fort,
c'était en février 1967,
Les Stones étaient des hommes marqués.
La police a reçu un pourboire
par les nouvelles du monde
qu'une fête de la drogue prenait
place chez Keith Richards
maison à West Wittering, dans le Sussex.
Et ils l'ont pillé sur un
Dimanche soir de février.
C'était le fameux buste
où Marianne Faithfull
n'était vêtu que d'un tapis de fourrure.
Tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé, c'est
cendres de cigarettes de marijuana
dans un cendrier, quelques amphétamines
qui étaient en fait, je
croire une ordonnance.
Et le résultat était que Jagger était
condamné à trois
mois de prison pour les pilules.
Et les Keith Richards
a obtenu 12 mois pour permettre
sa maison à utiliser pour
cette prise de drogue infâme.
Personnellement j'étais énervé
pour eux, et très choqué.
Nous avons tous reçu l'ordre d'être très
très discret, de ne parler à aucun média.
Il y avait une sorte d'instruction générale
du bureau des Stones, à
ne rien faire pour exacerber,
qu'il s'agissait d'une situation grave.
Et donc nous étions tous, je
signifie définitivement, bouleversé,
et en détresse, et
inquiète et inquiète pour eux.
Alors que ces
arrestations encore renforcées
La rébellion des Stones
réputation, ils ont également mis de côté
le groupe pendant une bonne partie de la
l'année charnière de la contre-culture.
En attendant leur procès, ils
effectué une tournée européenne,
leur dernière série de spectacles
depuis plus de deux ans.
Et en mai, Brian Jones
a également été la cible d'un policier
raid et lui aussi se tiendrait
procès pour possession de drogue.
Cependant, sur la côte ouest des États-Unis,
la contre-culture
l'influence se propage sans entrave.
Et en juin 1967, le premier
grand festival pop a eu lieu à
Monterey, une ville côtière 100
milles au sud de San Francisco.
Il s'agirait d'une vitrine essentielle pour
les bandes du Haight Ashbury.
La scène de San Francisco
était très excité par cela.
Nous pouvions sentir que c'était la prochaine vague.
Et donc nous avons voulu pour eux,
si vous n'aviez pas entendu parler d'eux,
c'est maintenant ta chance de les voir, maintenant descends
et passer trois jours et les voir tous.
Monterey, transition importante incroyable,
catalyseur d'énormes changements, et
les gens sont venus ce week-end
en haut, mamans et papas
exécute six succès consécutifs dans le top 10,
L'Association, Simon et Garfunkel.
À la fin du week-end, tout le monde était
parler de Jimi
Hendrix, Jefferson Avion,
Otis Redding, grand frère
et la société holding.
Et le monde entier
avait tourné en trois jours.
Monterey a été le premier
des festivals de musique pop.
Et il y avait un grand sentiment autour de lui.
Il y avait beaucoup d'optimisme dans l'air,
avec l'odeur de la marijuana.
Et pour moi, en regardant ce festival,
le point culminant était Janis Joplin.
Parce que je mettrais en scène Hendrix,
et j'avais vu The Who.
Je savais à quel point ils étaient bons,
Je m'étais envolé avec Hendrix.
Mais quand Janis Joplin est monté sur scène
et ouvrit la bouche, je
vient de faire deux pas en arrière.
Je n'avais juste jamais entendu un
femme chante comme ça dans ma vie.
Tout le monde était là,
Derek Taylor, les Beatles
le publiciste a mis tout cela ensemble.
Et beaucoup de monde était là.
Donc, beaucoup de gens l'ont vue le tuer.
Je veux dire qu'elle était super ce soir-là.
Plutôt que d'être dans une zone relativement petite,
américain semi-provincial
ville, tout d'un coup
San Francisco défiait LA.
LA était la côte ouest
centre de musique populaire
avec les films, et tout ça, c'était LA.
Et San Fransisco
avait très peu de part là-dedans.
Mais maintenant, le reconnaissant
Mort était San Francisco,
Janis Joplin était San Francisco.
San Francisco, que
été, est devenu une musique pop
capitale là où elle n'était pas auparavant.
Et en présence de cela
festival historique était un Rolling Stone.
Brian Jones, toujours en attente de jugement,
s'était rendu à l'événement, désireux d'assister
de première main les fruits de
cette nouvelle contre-culture.
Brian Jones apparaissant dans le public à
Monterey Pop, traîner avec Nico était
important pour la scène,
ils ont reconnu que comme
Royauté britannique du rock
oindre le festival.
Les Stones y étaient donc représentés.
Ce serait le fondement de
ce qui les conduirait à Altamont parce que
ils se sentaient quelque peu séparés
de ce sous-sol branché
mouvement et ils ont vraiment
voulait en faire partie.
Jagger voulait particulièrement cela pour son groupe.
Mais ce n'était ni The Stones,
ni les actes de la côte ouest qui
fournirait le définitif
déclaration musicale de ce
nouvel état d'esprit contre-culturel.
Dans un élan créatif remarquable, avec le LP
L'orchestre du club Lonely Hearts du sergent Pepper,
et le single All You Need
c'est l'amour, c'était les Beatles
qui a capturé l'esprit
de l'été de l'amour.
1967 appartenait vraiment aux Beatles.
Il se passait tout ce truc
sur la côte ouest.
Mais "Tout ce dont vous avez besoin, c'est de l'amour",
c'était tellement bien pour son temps.
Un été d'amour qui
était, comme toutes les meilleures fleurs,
ils meurent juste après quelques mois.
Mais "All You Need is Love" était la chanson,
la seule chanson qui symbolisait cela.
Ils avaient aussi le sergent Pepper
sur le marché de l'album qui,
même les critiques du Times
dire que c'est de l'art authentique.
Ce n'est pas de la musique pop, c'est de l'art.
Dans toute ma carrière de suivi de la musique,
et maintenant ça fait 50, 60 ans,
il n'y avait jamais rien
et n'a pas été depuis
quelque chose comme le sergent Pepper.
C'était grand, sergent
Pepper a époustouflé tout le monde.
Tout le monde a trouvé quelque chose à aimer.
C'était juste une musique puissante et puissante.
Fin juillet,
Jagger et Richards
a fait appel avec succès
contre leurs convictions.
Et le couple était à nouveau des hommes libres.
Déterminé à suivre le rythme des Beatles,
Les Stones se sont rapidement assemblés et émis
leurs propres apports
à l'été de l'amour.
Mais le single We Love You,
et l'album qui a suivi,
le très décrié
Demande des majestés sataniques,
offrait un moment moins festif
vision du temps,
et n'a pas réussi à sonner avec
l'ambiance utopique de l'époque.
Les Rolling Stones, et la paix et l'amour
pourraient sembler des compagnons de lit improbables.
Mais Jagger et Richards étaient là
à l'enregistrement de All You Need is Love.
Et en fait leur single
qui en découle,
"We Love You", je pense que c'est un chef d'oeuvre.
Les Rolling Stones sont,
et Jagger et Richards
en particulier sont, en plein
la ligne de tir à cet endroit.
Alors, la paix et l'amour avec un bord,
parce qu'ils sont
ciblés et victimisés.
Ce n'était pas quelque chose comme
"Tout ce dont vous avez besoin, c'est de l'amour".
C'était sardonique.
C'était ironique, presque,
la façon dont ils ont chanté ça
Ce n'était pas inclusif et optimiste,
et ludique, amusant et international.
Donc les Stones ne jouaient pas vraiment au ballon.
Les pierres sont durcies.
Ils n'ont jamais complètement mordu
tout l'idéalisme des années 60.
Ils étaient plus durs, c'était
comme une chose de Londres en partie.
C'étaient des enfants de la ville.
Alors tout cela revient à la terre,
et portez des fleurs dans votre
cheveux, et toutes ces affaires,
cela n'a pas vraiment fonctionné pour eux si bien.
Ils n'ont pas pensé parce que
tu es allé au parc
avec tes amis et agite un drapeau autour
que quelqu'un allait
renoncer à tout ce qui est important.
Ils ont tout à fait compris que
cela n'arriverait jamais.
Et la réticence des Stones
rejoindre l'optimisme ambiant,
a été confirmé par les événements les plus inquiétants
qui s'est passé pendant l'été de l'amour.
En juin 1967, 10 000 paix
les marcheurs ont été violemment attaqués
par la police lors d'une
manifestation à Los Angeles.
Alors que le mois suivant,
des émeutes raciales ont éclaté à Detroit
faisant des dizaines de morts et des centaines de blessés.
Alors même que l'été de
l'amour offrait ça
sorte de vision d'un monde nouveau,
il y avait plein de problèmes.
Tout n'a pas disparu
parce que tu as pris une pilule un jour.
"Nous pouvons transformer les choses en fumant du pot."
Ce n'était tout simplement pas réaliste.
Et bientôt tout le monde a appris
à quel point c'était irréaliste.
La croissance de la
la contre-culture se produit exactement
en même temps que le noir
le ghetto se lève en force,
à Detroit, et dans de nombreux autres endroits.
Donc, vous avez ces deux simultanés,
pas exactement lié
mouvements, mais les deux
te donner le sentiment que
tout est en train de changer.
Et beaucoup de choses sont assiégées
d'une manière qu'ils n'avaient jamais été auparavant.
Mais certainement les émeutes
dans les ghettos noirs sont
le plus déstabilisant
vigueur dans le pays,
et celui qui terrifie
les blancs le plus,
encore plus que les cheveux longs
rock and rollers, clairement.
La scène était
ensemble pour des temps plus difficiles à suivre.
Et au tout début de
1968 la contre-culture
foi dans les autorités
s'est encore effondré.
La victoire au Vietnam était
toujours présentée comme une certitude,
la fin inévitable d'une juste croisade.
Mais les reportages
diffusé pendant l'offensive du Têt
offert à toute l'Amérique un
vision très différente de la guerre.
William Westmoreland, qui est
le général d'armée commandant
pour les États-Unis au Vietnam
est rentré en Amérique
à l'automne 1967 et dit
que la guerre est gagnée,
et que nous n'avons rien à craindre,
et que nous sommes sur le point de tourner
le coin, et bien sûr,
célèbre il y a de la lumière
au bout du tunnel.
Et puis à la fin de
janvier 1968, vous avez
toutes les grandes villes du Sud-Vietnam,
et chaque avant-poste militaire majeur
attaqué simultanément
en l'honneur de la fête du Têt.
Et vous avez des Vietnamiens, dont certains qui
avait travaillé avant l'ambassade américaine,
à l'intérieur de l'ambassade américaine en l'attaquant.
Et ces images de gens
à l'intérieur de l'enceinte de l'ambassade,
ainsi que le général
chaos dans tout le pays,
avoir un effet très dramatique et immédiat.
Il était très clair que le
la lumière au bout du tunnel
n'existait vraiment pas,
c'était un fantasme
qui était vendu au peuple américain
justifier leurs fils
aller combattre cette guerre.
Une fois que cela est devenu une partie de
la conscience des gens de ce que
se passait au Vietnam,
oui, le vent a commencé à tourner.
Mais oui, il y avait une résistance à cela.
Mon pays, à tort ou à raison.
C'était quelque chose que vous
entendu tout le temps à l'époque.
Même si le Vietnam était
pas justifiable tu devais
mettez-vous derrière, et jeune
des gens qui étaient en quelque sorte
devrait aller se battre
cette guerre à laquelle nous pensons,
Eh bien, je ne pense pas, je
ne le vois pas de cette façon.
La bataille était lancée.
Et cette bataille n'était pas
limité au territoire américain.
Les mouvements de jeunesse et de paix
étaient actifs à l'international.
Et en Europe de grandes manifestations ont été
organisée pour s'opposer à la guerre du Vietnam.
Et bien que la Grande-Bretagne ait
vu des marches pacifiques
pour le désarmement nucléaire
depuis le début de la décennie,
en mars 1968 à l'extérieur
l'ambassade des États-Unis à Londres,
les protestations ont dégénéré en violence.
Après que les fleurs se soient fanées
il y a eu une confrontation avec la réalité.
Et la confrontation avec la réalité,
Le Vietnam devenait un problème
qui se propagent parmi les jeunes
des gens partout dans le monde.
C'était vraiment la guerre froide
devenir incontrôlable, Vietnam.
Les jeunes vies sont perdues
et les gens se posent des questions
pourquoi la Grande-Bretagne n'était pas
envoyer les forces,
mais il y avait quelques
soutien tacite des États-Unis.
Et parmi les manifestants,
observant que la police et
les manifestants se sont affrontés,
était Mick Jagger lui-même.
Depuis son procès, le rôle du leader
dans la contre-culture s'était transformée,
et il positionne maintenant
lui-même en première ligne.
Jagger est très intéressant
au regard de son rôle
dans la contre-culture
car il y a cet instinct
désir juste d'être crétin
et mettez vos deux doigts vers le haut.
Mais il a aussi cette éducation LSE.
Il est attiré par certains
des idées intellectuelles
qui sous-tendent ces notions
des différentes manières d'organiser la société.
Et il commence à apparaître à la télévision britannique
débattre avec Malcolm
Muggeridge et Mary Whitehouse,
et ces personnages qui représentaient
une attitude vraiment réactionnaire à l'époque.
L'occasion de continuer
TV et débat pourquoi il se sentait
la société était
organisé sur les mauvaises lignes
était très attrayant pour
lui, et puis ça devient
une partie de son écriture ainsi.
Et ce serait
arriver à un moment parfait.
L'ambiance conflictuelle dans
L'Europe s'est encore intensifiée
en mai lorsque des émeutes étudiantes ont éclaté à Paris.
La résistance s'étendit bientôt à
les ouvriers français eux-mêmes.
Et les rues sont devenues un champ de bataille,
avec des manifestants appelant à la révolution.
Dans cette turbulence
sont venus les Rolling Stones
nouveau single, "Jumping Jack Flash".
Vous aviez Grosvenor Square, mais vous avez aussi
avait du militantisme à Berlin, à Paris.
Et la jeunesse devenait
une force internationale,
d'une manière comme ça, et
Les Pierres, quand elles
Je suis revenu un peu mojo,
retour au dur R&B,
Ils étaient un grand symbole pour cela.
Alors quand tu avais les Beatles en 67,
incarnant tout
ce qui se passait alors,
Les pierres étaient prêtes,
vraiment, pour incarner
des énergies plus sombres qui étaient
genre de déroulement au cours de '68.
Je me souviens de la première fois que j'ai
entendu Jumping Jack Flash.
Je pensais comme wow,
Les Stones sont de retour.
Poussé par un riff, et conduit par
une sorte de rebelle
message, c'était exactement
ce que ce moment semblait appeler.
Cela les a lancés et a donné un coup de pied
tout avec le
"Jumping Jack Flash".
Je veux dire, né dans un ouragan de feu croisé,
et toute la langue
c'était dans cette chose,
c'était comme s'identifier
pour tous ces gens
J'avais l'impression que la vie était folle,
tu avais tout le Vietnam,
toutes ces autres choses qui se passent donc oui,
né dans un feu croisé re-coup de pied
tout, ça l'a rallumé.
Mais où les Stones étaient
revitalisé, l'américain
Le paysage politique
était sous le choc de nouvelles tragédies.
En avril, les droits civiques
chef Martin Luther King
avait été assassiné provoquant des émeutes
dans plus de 110 villes, le
la plus grande vague de troubles sociaux
le pays a connu
depuis la guerre civile.
Malgré les turbulences, il y avait un
personnalité politique porteuse d'espoir.
Robert Kennedy, le
frère cadet de tué
président John, était l'un des principaux candidats à
le Parti démocrate à
succède à Lyndon Johnson.
Un défenseur de l'humain
les droits et la justice sociale,
et un adversaire de la guerre du Vietnam,
il a suggéré que des changements pourraient se produire
de l'intérieur du système politique.
Pourtant, le 5 juin 1968, peu de temps après avoir remporté
la primaire californienne,
lui aussi a été assassiné.
Il représentait l'espoir, et
même les gens qui n'avaient pas
forcément investi dedans,
ils savaient qu'il était cela.
Et le vol a été ressenti très fortement
dans toute la culture des jeunes.
Ces deux assassinats
fait plus pour détruire
l'optimisme que toute autre chose dans ma vie.
Et bien sûr, vraiment, il
c'était trois assassinats
dans l'esprit de nous qui
a atteint sa majorité dans les années 60,
parce que c'était Jean
Kennedy, et puis c'était King,
et puis c'était Bobby Kennedy,
donc ce sont les trois plus
événements horribles de ma jeunesse.
La principale chose à laquelle je pense quand
tu repenses à cette période
était à quel point saturé
avec violence la culture était.
L'idée de mettre n'importe quel type
d'espoir dans l'un de ces chiffres
commençait à paraître légèrement ridicule.
Parce qu'ils étaient si nombreux à être tués,
violemment, sous nos yeux.
Et pour le
contre-culture l'idée
de paix et d'amour a perdu son charme,
et la révolution devint leur cri de ralliement.
Beaucoup de ceux qui sont impliqués
dans le mouvement des jeunes
uniquement pour le sexe,
drogues et rock'n'roll
maintenant devenu politiquement actif.
Et cela a atteint son ébullition
pointer du doigt une manifestation de masse
au National démocrate
Convention d'août 1968.
Eh bien, le démocrate
Convention nationale à Chicago
en forme de couronnement
de Hubert Humphrey,
Vice-président de Johnson et trié sur le volet
successeur dont personne ne se souciait.
Et le genre de National
Conseil des hippies non affiliés
qui s'appelaient les yippies,
déterminé à créer une diversion, une grève,
une manifestation à l'extérieur
le siège du congrès.
Et ils ont appelé les jeunes partout
le pays à descendre sur Chicago.
Le fait est que Chicago était dirigée par un maire,
un dur à cuire nommé Richard Daley.
Et il n'a tout simplement pas vu
n'importe quelle raison ces enfants
devrait être autorisé à faire
n'importe quoi, donc c'était une bataille
dans les rues à l'extérieur du
Convention démocratique.
Il y avait des milliers
des enfants qui se font tabasser,
et gazé lacrymogène, et transporté
en prison par le Chicago
Les policiers qui intervenaient,
à toutes fins utiles,
comme le festival de la police nazie dans les années 30.
Les émeutes policières au
Convention nationale démocrate
à Chicago en 1968 étaient
absolument une ligne de démarcation.
Cela radicaliserait totalement la culture des jeunes.
L'un des chants des manifestants à
la Convention de Chicago a été
Le monde entier est en train de regarder.
Et qu'il y avait ça
sens d'une fois que vous avez vu cela
tu ne peux pas détourner le regard tu ne peux pas
ne pas le voir, vous ne pouvez pas faire semblant.
Il fallait s'aligner d'un côté ou de l'autre.
Tout comme ces images de vicieux
la brutalité policière était
diffusé dans le monde entier,
Les Rolling Stones sortent
le single "Street Fighting Man"
inspiré du Grosvenor
Émeutes carrées plus tôt cette année-là.
Déclaré subversif
record, il a été instantanément interdit
par des stations de radio à Chicago et renforcé
les références anti-establishment du groupe.
Street Fighting Man a capturé le sentiment
du temps à la fois en Amérique et ici.
Mais Jagger a toujours été doué pour le sentir.
Et il a toujours eu cette capacité.
C'était l'un de ses
points forts en tant qu'auteur-compositeur.
Le sang coulait dans les rues.
Les températures étaient
monter, monter très vite.
Il avait tellement changé cette année-là de
"Tout ce dont vous avez besoin, c'est de l'amour" en 1967,
« Street Fighting Man » en 1968.
Le timing est tout et
faire sortir cette chanson
fait à ce moment
eux en plein centre de
l'air du temps d'une manière qu'ils ont probablement
ce n'était pas le cas depuis plusieurs années.
Et c'est vrai que le
sommet absolu des Beatles
était avec "Sergent Pepper's"
en 1967, bien que nous ayons
se rappeler que "Hey Jude"
était aussi en 1968 et Dylan's
les trucs politiques les plus puissants
était, en 1968, derrière lui.
Alors oui, je dirais
que les Rolling Stones,
à ce moment-là, étaient
probablement le plus puissant
force politique dans la scène rock and roll.
Et les pierres
la résurgence a été confirmée
à la fin de l'année avec
l'album "Banquet des mendiants".
Promu avec une soirée presse ivre,
il était temps pour
célébration, avec non seulement
Jagger et Richards, mais aussi Brian Jones,
avoir évité de justesse
prison au cours d'une année difficile.
Pourtant, la contre-culture plus large
ne se sentait pas si festif,
avec l'élection présidentielle
du candidat républicain
Richard Nixon en novembre,
verser du sel sur les plaies
qui avaient été infligées en 1968.
le nouvel album des Stones, et
sa piste d'ouverture exceptionnelle,
«Sympathie pour le diable», a démontré
leur pertinence continue
et la résistance à l'ordre existant.
Quiconque avait des doutes sur ce que The Stones
étaient jusqu'à après "satanique
Demande des Majestés"
avait ces doutes effacés par Beggars Banquet.
Si vous regardez les images du film
ils ont fait avec Jean-Luc Godard,
ils enregistrent "Sympathy For the Devil".
Et au cours de la réalisation du film,
vous voyez Jagger avoir
changer les paroles de
J'ai crié qui a tué Kennedy à
J'ai crié qui a tué les Kennedy ?
Quand tu dois faire une révision comme ça,
vous savez que vous opérez en plein
la pointe de ce qui se passe.
Comme la piste qui
a annoncé le banquet des mendiants,
ça ne pouvait pas avoir
été une déclaration plus forte.
Jagger a épousé un hédonisme avec
un plaisir de ça
une sorte de rôle de Lord of Misrule.
C'est ce qui ressort
dans des chansons comme "Sympathy For the Devil".
Il tombe amoureux, je pense,
avec ce rôle du Seigneur
de Misrule apportant le chaos
et turbulences dans son sillage.
Et c'est très attrayant mais tout aussi
plutôt dangereux en même temps.
Alors que les pierres étaient
occupés à se rétablir
dans ce rôle anarchique, une autre scène
s'était développé en Grande-Bretagne
au cours des deux dernières années.
Inspiré par les San
Francisco actes psychédéliques,
les groupes de l'underground
avait aussi expérimenté
avec des spectacles de lumière et des formes d'âme allongées
au club principal du circuit, UFO.
En 1968, la scène est
phares, The Pink Floyd
en tête d'affiche du premier grand concert gratuit
dans Hyde Park à Londres,
organisé par Blackhill Entreprises.
Et suite à la
succès du premier spectacle,
en juin 1969, ils mettent en scène
un événement encore plus grand,
avec le supergroupe Blind Faith.
Le spectacle de Pink Floyd a été déterminant parce qu'il était
beaucoup de monde dessus,
mais c'était une sorte de petite clé,
Nous n'en avons pas fait la promotion méchamment, pour ainsi dire.
Mais le spectacle Blind Faith
a été déterminant dans la mesure où
ils étaient une sorte d'amalgame
de la crème et du trafic,
c'étaient deux énormes groupes,
alors ils ont joué à Hyde Park.
Il y avait 150 000 personnes à cela.
Personne n'a été arrêté, il n'y a pas de bagarre,
c'était une belle journée, c'était très gentil de
Fae et bois à la manière anglaise.
Et et Sam Cutler
a ensuite été contacté par les Rolling Stones.
Rouler haut après leur
succès commercial l'année précédente,
ils ont estimé qu'un grand
concert gratuit avec en prime
les félicitations souterraines offriraient un
retour de haut niveau dans l'arène en direct.
En mai, ils avaient également tiré
le peu fiable Brian Jones,
et avait un nouveau guitariste dans
remorquer, Mick Taylor, pour qui
ce concert fournirait
l'introduction parfaite.
Une date a été fixée pour juillet,
l'attente est grande pour l'événement.
Et puis, deux jours avant le spectacle,
ils ont reçu des nouvelles que
Jones avait été retrouvé mort.
Quelques jours avant le spectacle, Brian est décédé.
Alors la question, bien sûr,
devient immédiatement
dans des situations comme ça,
Alors, que fais tu?
Eh bien, il y a bien sûr
dans le monde de la musique,
comme toutes les entreprises théâtrales,
il y a une chose que le spectacle doit continuer.
Mick et Keith fondamentalement, ont estimé que
il devrait être tenu comme un mémorial à Brian.
Entreprises Blackhill
commencé avec beaucoup
les groupes hippies qui jouent;
Pink Floyd, Tyrannosaure Rex,
puis Blind Faith un peu plus tard.
Les Stones sont encore une chose différente
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
joué pendant quelques années,
pas depuis les bustes, il s'était passé tant de choses.
Et ils sont sortis ils
a libéré les papillons
qui mourut rapidement, pas de grand augure.
Je pensais que c'était l'un des
les concerts les plus horribles
J'ai vu les Rolling Stones jouer.
Ils étaient sous répétés.
Mick Taylor ne savait tout simplement pas si
il venait ou allait
tout au long de celui-ci.
Jagger dansant sur le
papillons morts était probablement
le plus terriblement comique
chose que j'ai jamais vue.
Et ils étaient tellement terriblement tristes.
Dommage qu'ils se soient sentis obligés de le faire.
En dehors de
le spectacle lui-même,
le concert était un grand
événement réunissant
une audience de plus d'un quart de million,
qui étaient inconscients de
Les défauts de Stones sur scène.
Dans son atmosphère communautaire,
il faisait écho à l'unité pacifique
du San Fransisco
événements qu'il imitait.
Et en hommage au célèbre
spectacles du parc du Golden Gate,
la sécurité a été supervisée
par une version très britannique
des Hell's Angels.
Tout le monde était impeccable
s'est bien comporté, personne n'est allé à l'hôpital,
personne n'a été poignardé, non
un a été abattu, rien de tout cela.
Et il y avait ces gars
qui roulait sur des motos BSA 125,
qui en voudrait un
se lever du scooter,
qui s'appelaient Hell's
Les anges, et bien sûr avaient
rien à faire
avec les Hell's Angels américains.
Les Hell's Angels en Angleterre,
ce n'étaient pas des Hell's Angels de Californie.
Ils ont fait dessiner leurs couleurs
sur leurs cuirs à la craie.
Et ils étaient dans les coulisses
au concert de Hyde Park
servir du thé, donc si c'est
ce que les Rolling Stones
Je pensais que les Hell's Angels étaient,
ils étaient dans une surprise assez sévère.
Et bientôt les Stones viendraient
face à face avec les vrais Hell's Angels.
Après le concert de Hyde Park,
le groupe préparait une nouvelle tournée,
quelque chose qu'ils désespérément
nécessaires pour s'organiser.
Malgré leur résurgence dans le courant dominant,
les membres du groupe eux-mêmes étaient fauchés.
En 1965, directeur
Andrew Oldham avait apporté
Comptable new-yorkais, Allen
Klein dans l'équipe des Stones.
Et les heures supplémentaires ce négociateur coriace
avait fait ses preuves dans le groupe.
Bientôt musclé Oldham hors de l'image,
en 1968, il était le seul manager du groupe.
Et sa société Abkco, avait le contrôle sur
leurs affaires financières et
leurs comptes bancaires collectifs.
Et faire en sorte que Klein débloque ses fonds
s'avérait de plus en plus difficile.
Ils en avaient marre
Allen Klein parce qu'ils
ne pourrait jamais tirer d'argent d'Allen.
Alors les voici, ce groupe de renommée mondiale,
pratiquement affamés, et ils
devait faire une tournée en Amérique.
En gros, ils savaient que s'ils le faisaient
avec Allen Klein, Allen Klein finirait
avec la part du lion des recettes.
Et ils font cet énorme
tournée et n'ont pas d'argent.
Alors ils ont réussi, je ne sais trop comment,
séduire Allen Klein
neveu Ronnie Schneider
loin de l'entreprise de son oncle, Abkco,
venir travailler pour The
Stones et faire cette tournée.
En août, j'ai quitté mon oncle.
Quelques semaines après ça
J'ai reçu un appel téléphonique de
Mick Jagger dit nous
veux que tu fasses cette tournée.
Et je leur ai dit que j'avais quitté Abkco.
Et ils ont dit bien nous savons.
Et j'ai dit que tu dois obtenir
la permission de mon oncle pour que
Je peux y aller, je ne veux pas
J'ai un problème familial ici.
Alors ils ont dit qu'ils obtiendraient sa permission.
Et ce qu'ils ont réellement fait
c'était, c'était la première fois
J'ai entendu de Sam Cutler, ce qu'ils ont fait était
ils l'ont emmené au Royaume-Uni et l'ont renvoyé.
Au tir
Klein, les atouts du groupe
ont été immédiatement congelés,
et la série d'émissions américaines
est devenu encore plus crucial
pour leur survie financière.
Et à la fin du
été, tandis que les préparatifs
pour la tournée étaient en cours,
une figure majeure de
la scène de la côte ouest est arrivée à Londres.
Et d'ici les graines de
le concert gratuit était semé.
Ce qui s'est passé, c'est que le directeur,
enfin un des gérants
de The Grateful Dead
était un gars qui s'appelait Rock Scully, un homme adorable.
Il est venu à Londres, et un
cher ami à lui était le chef
d'Epic Records, d'un type qui s'appelle
Chesley Millikin à Londres.
Et Chesley Millikin,
à son tour était de bons amis
avec Keith et Mick, donc
il a présenté Rock Scully
de The Grateful Dead à Keith et Mick.
Et Rock était fondamentalement un grand prosélyte
pour les avantages de la gratuité
concerts, comme c'était merveilleux,
ce qui se passait à San Francisco.
Rock est convoqué
à la maison de Keith Richards.
Et Rock dit que vous venez
aux États Unis,
vous devez jouer gratuitement
concert au Golden Gate Park.
je sais exactement comment
fais ça, je peux te réparer.
Mais ensuite ils parlent aussi
sur la façon dont les Stones devraient
jouer au Taj Mahal, et tout
sortes d'idées folles surgissent.
Et Rock s'en va
sans vraiment y penser
il venait de proposer d'organiser un concert pour
Les Rolling Stones à San
Francisco, mais Keith s'en souvenait.
Et la perspective de la tête d'affiche
un autre concert gratuit au cœur de
bientôt la contre-culture
est devenu encore plus attrayant.
Au milieu du mois d'août, le
Festival de Woodstock de trois jours
devenu un événement marquant,
réunissant 32 actes musicaux,
et un public de près d'un demi-million.
Malgré les difficultés de l'année précédente,
et l'élection de Richard Nixon,
cet événement pacifique et harmonieux a prouvé que
la contre-culture était unie et florissante.
La contre-culture était en
état très sain en 1969.
Et Woodstock était la marée haute, en quelque sorte.
Je pense qu'en 1969 nous avons vraiment
pensait que nous gagnions.
Nous pensions que nous grandissions,
et nous étions une force imparable.
J'étais adolescent au
temps, et c'est certainement ainsi
Je me sentais, aussi naïf que cela puisse paraître aujourd'hui.
Mais je pense que le point de vue selon lequel
je tenais était celui qui était
largement admis, que nous étions
va changer le monde.
Nous le croyions sincèrement.
Et en 1969, nous n'avons pas
pense que tout peut nous arrêter.
Fin octobre 1969
L'équipe des Stones est arrivée à Los Angeles
cherchant à sécuriser au moins 15
les lieux de la prochaine tournée,
mais sans plans
que ce soit pour un concert gratuit.
Le 7 novembre, à
Université d'État du Colorado
le groupe est monté sur une scène américaine
pour la première fois en trois ans.
Mais comme pour le spectacle de Hyde Park,
en tant que groupe live, ils étaient encore rouillés.
Il est apparu dans leur premier spectacle,
combien terriblement mal préparé
ils étaient pour la tournée.
Et juste avant ce spectacle, je
a été prié de les présenter.
je n'y ai même pas pensé
ce que j'allais dire.
Mais une minute avant le
spectacle, je me suis précipité sur scène
et est devenu "le plus grand groupe de rock and roll
dans le monde, les Rolling Stones !"
Tout le monde a applaudi, le
groupe est sorti et a joué.
À la fin du spectacle, Mick a quitté la scène,
et alors qu'il quittait la scène et me dépassait,
il est allé "je veux parler à
vous", n'ayant pas l'air très heureux.
Nous sommes donc allés dans le
vestiaire tout seul,
et il a regardé il a dit
"mec, ne nous appelle pas les plus grands"
"groupe de rock and roll dans le
monde, c'est embarrassant."
A quoi j'ai répondu "eh bien
soit vous l'êtes, soit vous ne l'êtes pas."
Ils sont immédiatement retournés en répétition.
Ils ont obtenu la scène sonore pour
"Ils tirent sur des chevaux, n'est-ce pas",
ce film sur le terrain de Warner Brothers à Burbank
en Californie, et ils ont répété solidement.
Et à partir du prochain spectacle,
Les Stones ont prouvé qu'ils étaient
le plus grand rocher et
roll band dans le monde.
Alors qu'ils se déplaçaient vers l'ouest
de Los Angeles au Texas,
Alabama à New York
Madison Square Garden,
ils se sont améliorés à chaque spectacle.
Aux côtés de l'écrivain Stanley Booth,
qui faisait partie du cercle restreint des Stones,
Journaliste du New York Times
Michael Lydon a pu
être témoin de première main de la
remarquable ascension du groupe.
J'étais embarqué dans la tournée,
Je n'ai jamais payé une chambre d'hôtel,
Je n'ai jamais payé un billet d'avion,
Je faisais juste partie de l'entourage.
Et, comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
c'était une mission de prune.
C'était extrêmement génial.
Je me souviens avoir pensé, Stanley
et je me regarderais
pendant que les Stones étaient sur scène,
et nous étions derrière les amplis.
Et nous allons comme, drôle
chance entre eux,
réaliser où nous sommes en ce moment est où
chaque hippie n'importe où
dans le monde veut être,
en plein dans le groupe avec les Rolling Stones.
Et c'était très amusant.
Ils étaient brûlants, et ils
traversaient le pays.
Et ils avaient obtenu
de mieux en mieux et de mieux en mieux.
En 1969, les Stones étaient incroyables.
Je veux dire qu'ils étaient juste magistraux.
Je me souviens quand les lumières
étaient en panne, et tout ce que vous pouvez voir
étaient les lumières rouges sur leurs amplificateurs.
et Madison Square Garden dans le noir.
Et je me souviens avoir pensé
Dieu, en quelques secondes
Les Rolling Stones sont
va jouer ici.
Je me souviens à quel point c'était excitant.
Et ils étaient super.
J'ai vu les Stones dessus
tournée au Forum de Los Angeles.
J'avais des billets pour le deuxième spectacle,
qui était censé
commencer à 11, il a commencé à deux.
Les Stones sont montés sur scène à
quatre, et ils ont ensuite continué
mettre ce qui était le
le plus grand spectacle de rock and roll
Je n'avais jamais vu à ce moment de ma vie.
Et à ce jour, 50 ans
plus tard, reste l'un des plus grands
spectacles de rock and roll que j'ai jamais
vus, ils étaient incroyables.
Mais pendant qu'ils mettaient
un spectacle explosif après
un autre, dans les coulisses
des plans s'élaboraient pour
un concert gratuit sur la côte ouest.
Nous avons joué à Oakland,
et tous les Grateful Dead
les gens se sont présentés à
ce spectacle, et ce genre de
balle commencée
à Londres à propos de "ne serait-ce pas"
"Ce serait génial si vous jouiez un concert gratuit
"avec les Grateful Dead",
lentement en quelque sorte accéléré.
Et c'est devenu, c'est devenu
le cas où quelqu'un de
Les Rolling Stones avaient
sortir en Californie
et rencontrer les gens
des Grateful Dead
et prendre au sérieux
si cela était possible.
J'ai donc été choisi pour y aller.
L'original de Rock Scully
le plan était d'obtenir un permis
pour un concert du Jefferson Airplane,
et les morts reconnaissants
puis 24 heures avant
le spectacle annonce
nous avons un invité spécial.
Et ils ont parlé de
avoir les Hell's Angels
créez un garde d'escorte et apportez les pierres
de l'aéroport au
concert, c'était l'idée.
Ça aurait pu être fantastique,
Les Rolling Stones, non ?
Mais les responsables
des Rolling Stones
les stratégies commerciales ont commencé à penser
ça devient trop
précieuse une opportunité.
Assez rapidement The Rolling
Gestion des pierres,
sous la forme de Ronnie
Schneider et un type étrange
nommé John James qui
s'est attaché aux Stones,
ils ont pris le contrôle de
situation, "nous allons gérer cela."
Et contacté le maire de San Francisco,
et ce n'était pas bon
idée, qui a mis fin à toute perspective
d'obtenir ce concert à San Francisco.
Demander directement des permis
pour un concert à Golden
Gate Park, l'équipe des Stones
faire sonner l'alarme
dans le bureau du maire.
The Grateful Dead avait imaginé un moins
événement de haut niveau, avec des offres
fait dans les coulisses.
Mais l'idée de 300 000
Ventilateurs de pierres descendant
sur une ville mal équipée pour un tel
un grand festival tout de suite
fermer l'idée.
Maintenant, un nouvel emplacement était nécessaire,
avec peu de temps pour l'organiser.
Et tandis que les alternatives
étaient envisagés,
l'implication de la
Les Hell's Angels sont devenus officiels.
Rock m'a dit que nous aurions besoin du
Des anges pour garder les générateurs.
Il n'y a pas d'électricité là-bas,
donc ce que tu as fait c'était que tu devais
location de gros générateurs pour
produire suffisamment d'électricité
faire le son, et
lumières, et tout ça.
Et je suis allé rencontrer les Hell's Angels.
Et les Hell's Angels sont allés jusqu'au bout
pour expliquer qu'ils n'étaient pas flics.
Bref, ils étaient contents
s'asseoir près des générateurs
et empêcher les gens de déconner
avec les générateurs à coup sûr.
Parce qu'ils aiment aussi la musique.
L'idée au départ était qu'ils se gareraient
leurs vélos devant la scène.
La beauté de ce serait
être que personne ne le ferait
précipiter la scène, ou c'était la théorie.
Pendant que ces plans se développaient,
documentaire de renom
cinéastes Les frères Maysles
ont été amenés à bord de la tournée pour capturer
les spectacles du Madison Square Garden,
et le concert gratuit qui a suivi.
Et pendant leur New York
jambe, les pierres elles-mêmes
ont fait un retour à l'émission dans laquelle ils avaient
si célèbre a choqué l'Amérique en 1964.
Ils avaient bouclé la boucle.
Pourtant, en tant que voix de leur génération,
ils étaient plus pertinents que jamais.
Ils sont apparus sur Ed
Sullivan's Show cinq ans après
la première apparition, quelle différence.
Ils jouent "Donne-moi
Shelter", cette chanson qui
symbolise vraiment ainsi
une grande partie de ce qui se passait
à cette époque, le tumulte de la culture.
Ils sont tellement bons
atteindre, c'est un groupe de pop,
c'est un groupe de rock, ils sont sur Ed Sullivan
faire "Gimme Shelter" qui est
une chanson très subversive, colérique et sombre.
Viol, meurtre, c'est juste un coup de feu.
Qu'y a-t-il au coin de la rue?
Nous arrivons à la fin de la décennie.
Les choses semblent assez sombres socialement.
Musicalement, ils étaient probablement
atteignant un nouveau type de sommet.
Les Stones ont-ils fait mieux
chanson que "Gimme Shelter"?
Je ne suis pas sûr, c'est une pièce incroyable.
Ce n'est pas la pop telle que nous la connaissons.
C'est vraiment les Stones au top.
En novembre
28 ans, à cheval sur la critique
acclamé pour leur
performances, et conscient que
dans le monde de la musique, ils étaient
la plus grande nouvelle en Amérique,
ils ont tenu une conférence de presse publiquement
annoncer le prochain concert gratuit.
J'ai lu dans un des journaux que
vous donnerez gratuitement
concert à San Fransisco.
Nous faisons un gratuit
concert à San Fransisco
le 6décembre, et l'emplacement n'est pas
Parc du Golden Gate,
malheureusement, mais c'est quelque part
à côté, juste un peu plus grand.
Pas seulement des pierres
spectacle, la programmation incluse
les plus grands noms de
la scène de la côte ouest.
De The Grateful Dead,
et l'avion Jefferson,
à Crosby, Stills, Nash et Young.
Pourtant, un emplacement n'a toujours pas été confirmé,
avec l'hippodrome Sears Point de Dick Saint John
l'alternative la plus probable
au parc du Golden Gate.
Ils ont dit que Ron le ferait
sortir et négocier
un accord avec Sears Point Raceway?
Alors je me suis envolé pour San Francisco,
Je me suis assis avec Dick Saint
John, et il a essentiellement dit
"Eh bien votre concert gratuit nous avons besoin de 100 000 $"
"pour tout nettoyer, il nous faut 100 000 $"
"pour couvrir 10 millions
police d'assurance en dollars."
Ils m'ont donné une autre raison pour laquelle ils avaient besoin d'argent.
Et puis aussi nous avons besoin de tous les droits sur un film.
Alors j'ai dit tout d'abord,
c'est un concert gratuit.
Nous ne vous payons pas
300 000 $, alors cet accord a explosé.
C'était deux
jours avant l'événement,
et l'équipe des Stones était maintenant désespérée.
Et à ce moment-là, un nouveau
emplacement leur a été proposé.
L'autoroute d'Altamont,
60 milles à l'est de San Francisco
était un hippodrome éloigné situé au milieu
les collines du comté d'Alameda.
Propriété d'un ancien coureur
chauffeur, Dick Carter c'était
un candidat improbable
pour un grand festival de rock.
Dick Carter, son plus grand
public jamais auparavant
était-il avait 6 000 personnes
se présenter à un derby de démolition.
C'est jeudi après-midi,
et les gens des Stones
ne sais pas exactement quoi
faire, mais ils y ont jeté un coup d'œil.
Alors ils obtiennent un trafic
hélicoptère de l'un des locaux
stations de radio et ils prennent Rock Scully,
et Michael Lange, le
producteur de Woodstock
qui s'est présenté pour une raison ou une autre.
Et ils s'envolent pour Altamont.
Rock regarde et il
voit l'asphalte taché d'huile,
du verre brisé partout,
juste cet horrible panorama.
Et il regarde dehors
qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Et il entend Michael
Lange allez c'est parfait.
Nous pouvons le faire ici.
Et comme ça
Altamont a eu le feu vert.
Avec seulement une journée pour préparer le lieu,
l'équipe de la route s'est précipitée
pour mettre en place ce nouveau site.
L'équipe des Stones avait
déjà commencé à construire la scène
et organiser la
installation d'éclairage à Sears Point.
Et cela a été simplement démonté
et ré-érigé à Altamont.
Il n'y avait pas le temps d'évaluer correctement
ou repenser les plans originaux,
bien qu'à son arrivée
directeur de tournée Sam Cutler
a immédiatement eu des inquiétudes.
Le problème majeur, majeur était que la scène
qui avait été parfait pour Sears Point,
parce que ça allait
être sur le flanc de la colline,
était maintenant au pied d'une colline.
Et la scène était à hauteur de genoux, donc c'était
sans effort facile pour les gens de s'y mettre.
Le spectacle était un samedi,
J'ai vu l'endroit à midi
vendredi pour la première
temps et a été horrifié.
Et il y avait déjà
100 000 personnes sur place.
Et cette étape était isolée
au milieu d'eux.
Nous avons donc essayé de faire
barricades de camions et autres
autour d'elle et préparez-vous pour un spectacle.
Et je savais que le vendredi ça allait être
un énorme, énorme problème d'ordre public.
Le spectacle est allé de l'avant,
sans nourriture ni eau,
aucune commodité d'aucune sorte,
et uniquement des services médicaux de base sur place.
Les 300 000 spectateurs du concert
qui ont afflué sur le lieu
n'avaient aucune idée de ce qui les attendait.
C'était la toute fin du
'60s, la dernière congrégation de masse
de la contre-culture
avant le début d'une nouvelle décennie.
Cela aurait dû être une fête.
Le soleil s'est levé, c'était une belle journée.
Et puis à un moment donné
ils laissent officiellement entrer les gens,
et cette foule de jeunes
les gens sont venus se précipiter
la colline avec les couvertures, et essayant
s'emparer d'un
tout petit espace pour s'asseoir.
Et l'ambiance était définitivement
joyeux et amusant, et j'aime
oui ça va être comme
Woodstock, c'est groovy.
je n'ai pas pu le faire
Woodstock mais je suis là.
Mais ça n'a pas pris longtemps
pour que l'ambiance change.
Le problème était qu'il y avait beaucoup de LSD,
mauvais acide, mauvaises drogues, beaucoup d'alcool bon marché.
Donc, au moment où le spectacle
ouvert le samedi midi,
tu en avais trois, 400 000
les gens complètement hors de lui.
Et les combats ont commencé, et il
juste dégénéré à partir de là.
Avec les Hell's Angels,
une présence visible autour de la scène
et sur tout le site du festival,
à midi le premier acte parut, Santana.
A mi-parcours du spectacle
Militant pacifiste de San Francisco
et promoteur, Bert Kanegson
a été la première de nombreuses victimes
faire face à la colère des
concerts force de sécurité brutale.
Ce Latino en surpoids,
tout nu, fouetté hors de
son cerveau sur le LSD qui était probablement lacé
avec de la méthédrine, et
vin gourmand de Red Mountain.
Il erre en bas de la colline vers l'avant
de la scène où se trouvent les Hell's Angels.
Et c'est comme une mauvaise nouvelle tout de suite.
Et Bert voit ça
passe, et il saute.
Et il commence le
ce tous les hommes sont frères,
et suppliant les anges
ne pas battre ce gars.
Ils se retournent contre Bert, et
ils font pleuvoir des queues de billard.
Ils l'ont si bien casser,
il a 60 points de suture dans la tête.
Ce n'était que le début.
La présence des Anges sur scène
et à l'avant du public a augmenté.
Et comme l'avion Jefferson a pris
leurs places pour la deuxième représentation,
il était difficile de distinguer
le groupe des motards.
Plus de la foule était
isolé pour les coups.
Et quand l'avion est
le chanteur Marty Balin
tenté d'intervenir, lui aussi a été agressé.
Ces gars étaient les
chose réelle, ils n'étaient pas
le petit club de vélo qui
qu'ils avaient à Hyde Park.
Ils ont des psychopathes,
et meurtriers, ex cons,
et Dieu sait quoi dans
là, ce sont de mauvaises nouvelles.
C'est bon,
c'est un peu bizarre ici.
Hé mec, je voudrais mentionner
que les Hell's Angels
vient d'écraser Marty Balin au visage,
et l'a assommé un peu.
J'aimerais vous en remercier.
Il y a d'autres moyens.
Hé attends, est-ce que c'est allumé?
Si tu me parles,
Je vais te parler.
Je ne te parle pas mec, je parle à
les gens qui m'ont frappé
chanteur principal dans la tête.
Vous parlez à mon peuple.
Alors laissez-moi vous dire ce qui se passe.
Vous êtes ce qui se passe.
Hé ho!
Non.
Buster, tiens-le, tiens-le.
C'était effrayant, c'était effrayant.
Sorte de rationnellement effrayant, nous
n'inventaient rien.
Nous avions vu la vraie laideur
et blessant et
sauvagerie sous nos yeux.
Les Hell's Angels étaient horribles.
Et il semblait presque plus ainsi
parce qu'au cours de la dernière décennie
il y avait eu une sorte de
mythe à quel point ils étaient cool.
Vraiment important à comprendre,
le San Fransisco
chapitre des Hell's Angels
était situé dans le Haight Ashbury.
Ils étaient bien connus
dans les coulisses de Grateful Dead
et des concerts Jefferson Airplane.
Ils ont fait du vélo avec les équipes de la route.
Ils étaient entièrement
groupe différent de Hell's Angels
que de dire le bureau à domicile à Oakland.
Les problèmes avec les Hell's Angels au
site éventuel du concert à Altamont
étaient tous devant la scène.
Et ils ont été presque entièrement causés
par les membres du chapitre de San Jose.
Et le chapitre de San Jose
était entièrement différent.
C'est à une heure de San
Francisco, ce ne sont pas des hippies.
Ils n'ont pas l'habitude d'aller au Filmore,
ils ne sont pas dans les coulisses
présences, elles sont démodées
Des voyous californiens, et c'étaient les gars
devant la scène avec les queues de billard.
Même s'ils étaient là
capter un positif
fin de la tournée des Stones,
Les frères Maysle
et leurs caméramans étaient
documentant maintenant le chaos croissant.
Et c'était le tour manager des Stones,
Sam Cutler, qui a tenté de rétablir l'ordre.
À bien des égards, je me sentais essentiellement impuissant.
Face à des gens qui
étaient déterminés à combattre
les uns les autres, qu'est-ce qu'un
faire petit anglais maigre?
Et au fur et à mesure que la journée avançait et que la violence
a empiré, j'ai été confronté à ce terrible
réalisé que mon groupe allait venir.
Les Rolling Stones allaient venir,
et nous devrons comparaître ici.
Et en début d'après-midi
en tant que The Flying Burrito Brothers
a commencé le troisième set du festival,
Les Stones sont arrivés le
piste de vitesse en hélicoptère.
Et presque immédiatement
ils ont été accueillis avec violence.
Mick est arrivé, et le reste de
Les Stones, moins Bill Wyman
et la première chose qui est arrivée a été
il est descendu de l'hélicoptère,
et un gamin dérangé sous acide l'a frappé.
Ils frappent
Mick, quelqu'un l'a frappé.
Donc c'était effrayant.
Et Mick est arrivé et
reçu des rapports de personnes
à quel point tout cela était épouvantable.
On nous a tous mis dans une petite roulotte.
Alors, au début
Je suis sûr que nous avons des histoires
que de la violence, mais nous n'avons pas vu
rien de tout cela et savoir ce qui se passait.
Mais vous pouvez le sentir, il y avait...
Je ne connais pas les situations ailleurs,
mais vous pouvez le sentir dans l'air.
Et cette humeur sinistre était suffisante
convaincre les habitants
têtes d'affiche, The Grateful Dead
d'abandonner complètement le concert.
Arrivant peu après The Stones,
seulement pour découvrir que
les membres de leur équipe de route
avait déjà été agressé
par les anges, ils ont décidé de renflouer.
Le groupe qui avait lancé l'idée même de
le concert gratuit, voulait
aucune partie de cet événement.
En fin de compte, The Grateful Dead a couru.
Ils se sont retirés, ils
vu qu'il y avait trop de violence.
S'ils auraient joué je pense
c'était peut-être un
un tout autre jeu de balle
au lieu de dire oh The Stones...
Si The Grateful Dead avait
y a joué deux ou trois
heure définie, je suis sûr que ce serait
ont adouci tout le monde,
Cela finira peut-être par endormir tout le monde.
Ils prenaient toutes les drogues et tout ça.
Mais le résultat final a été qu'ils ont couru.
Alors maintenant tu as eu ce temps de latence
avant la sortie des Stones.
Et toutes les mauvaises drogues, la violence,
et tout ça va
là-bas mais les pierres
est encore sorti et
exécutés, ils n'ont pas couru.
Après le départ de The Dead
Crosby, Stills, Nash et Young ont joué
aussi brefs qu'ils sont définis
pouvait gérer, les coups
par les Anges continuant
tout au long de leur prestation.
Après seulement une demi-heure
heure, ils sont rapidement sortis
l'étape et s'enfuit immédiatement d'Altamont.
Il ne restait plus que The Stones à jouer.
Et en l'absence de The Grateful Dead,
leur ensemble de titres n'était pas
en raison de commencer pendant des heures.
La foule est juste assise là,
ils ont été là toute la journée.
Il n'y a ni eau, ni toilettes, ni nourriture.
Ils sont coincés dans la hanche pour
hanche, épaule contre épaule.
Et ils sont là depuis plus de
deux heures sans rien faire.
Juste au moment où le soleil commence à se coucher
Sonny Barger et le
Le chapitre d'Oakland apparaît.
Ils avaient eu une réunion cet après-midi.
Et ils ont littéralement fait juste
conduire à travers la foule
descendez sur le devant de la scène, descendez,
garer leurs vélos, obtenir
off et assis sur la scène.
C'était un spectacle incroyable.
Et une fois l'obscurité tombée,
Les Stones sont enfin montés sur scène,
en infériorité numérique par les hordes
des anges tout autour d'eux.
Au début de leur set, ils ont réussi
pour s'élever au-dessus de l'atmosphère troublante.
Les Stones ont joué hors de leur peau,
et très probablement par peur.
Parce qu'à cette époque, les Hell's Angels
sont partout sur scène,
et s'ils arrêtaient de jouer
ils n'en sont peut-être même pas sortis vivants.
Et sous la contrainte, et avec
ce genre d'adrénaline qui coule
ils ont fait une sacrée performance.
C'était juste phénoménal,
juste Charlie et Wyman
avait le fond verrouillé,
les guitares sonnaient
comme des étincelles, et Jagger
chantait comme il le pensait,
comme aucune de ces sortes de caricatures folles
la il a tendance à aller, il
était réel à propos de cette chose.
Mais cette performance impressionnante
ne pouvait pas supprimer la brutalité
qui allait bientôt perturber leur set.
Et bien que plus tard certains membres du groupe aient affirmé
ils n'ont pas pu voir
toute l'étendue de la violence,
les caméras filmant
événements sur et autour de la scène
capturé un concert descendant dans le chaos.
Les choses sont allées de mal en pis.
Et vraiment, il n'y a pas de contrôle.
Il y a des bagarres partout,
les gens se précipitent sur scène,
être expulsé de la scène,
se bat devant la scène.
Nous étions plus que
conscient de ce qui se passait.
Toute la lumière était en contre-jour,
50 000 watts de rétroéclairage,
lumineux est votre salon.
Donc tout ce truc sur The
Les Rolling Stones ne savaient pas
ça se passait, et ça n'a pas été le cas
voir ce qui se passait
est une connerie complète et totale.
Et vous pouvez voir dans le film où Jagger est
danser autour et ses yeux
se produire dans le public.
Ae voit quelqu'un prendre
un coup de queue de billard,
et il fait une bombe et arrête de danser.
Jagger a tellement de commandement en tant qu'interprète.
Et le voir lutter, c'est terrifiant.
Allons-y ensemble, je n'en peux plus
que juste te demander, juste supplier
vous venez de le garder ensemble.
Tu peux le faire, c'est à l'intérieur
votre pouvoir, tout le monde.
Tout le monde, les Hell's Angels, tout le monde.
A ce moment-là certainement, les bandes
comme l'avion Jefferson
et les Rolling Stones ils
étaient des avatars, c'étaient des dieux.
Et les voir désespérés d'essayer d'arrêter
cette violence qui se produit
juste devant eux,
et à défaut, c'est inoubliable.
Vous pouviez le voir démanger dans les visages des gens
sur le devant de la scène,
juste regarder Jagger
et en disant s'il vous plaît arrêtez, aidez-nous.
C'est, nous regardons
tout meurt ici.
Et entre les chansons
tu avais ces silences de mort.
Et puis en quelque sorte alors
une sorte de bruit de têtes fêlées et
les gens crient "non" et
vouloir que tout s'arrête.
La chose de la fraternité humaine,
qui était le rêve hippie,
tout venait vraiment
décollé là, très très mal.
j'étais juste derrière le
amplis, pour que je puisse voir,
Je ne pouvais voir que ce que je pouvais voir.
Mais à un moment donné, Keith,
tout comme Marty Balin,
Keith s'arrête et dit
Hé, tu ne peux pas faire ça ici.
Et la musique s'est arrêtée.
Regarde chat, ce gars
là s'il ne l'arrête pas.
Écoutez, soit ces chats
Cool mec ou on ne joue pas.
Mais alors il y avait quelques
en quelque sorte, un autre de
ces attaques et toi
pouvait dire que c'était tout simplement horrible.
Et les gens étaient,
ils ressemblent à du poisson dans un bocal
et tu as fait tomber un
caillou, et tous les poissons
courraient aussi vite qu'ils le pouvaient.
C'était comme s'il y avait une place centrale,
où quelque chose de vraiment moche se passait.
Et les gens essayaient juste de s'enfuir
aussi vite qu'ils le pouvaient.
Je suis parti, j'ai juste marché, j'ai quitté la scène
et s'est en quelque sorte éloigné sur la petite colline.
Puis j'ai réalisé que je ne viendrais pas
à plus de ces choses
je ne vais pas en quelque sorte
crois le Woodstock,
Monterey Pop, le mythe de l'être humain n'existe plus.
Les Hell's Angels ont été une énorme erreur.
Nous ne sommes tout simplement pas tous frères et sœurs.
Il n'y a que des éléments de laideur,
et la méchanceté, et la méchanceté,
qui sont trop puissants pour cela.
Et la méchanceté déchaînée
au concert a abouti à un meurtre.
Meredith Hunter, étudiante de 18 ans,
pris dans une bagarre avec
les Anges devant la scène
fait l'erreur de tirer
une arme à feu sur ses agresseurs.
Il ne vivrait pas pour voir
la fin du set des Stones.
Enfin ils font "Under my Thumb",
et un gars a sorti un
pistolet, j'ai tiré deux fois,
peut-être 60 pieds devant la scène,
et a été poignardé à mort
par l'un des Hell's Angels.
Le groupe s'est arrêté.
Tout d'un coup on m'a dit "Ron, Ron
nous avons besoin de l'ambulance,
un gars a été poignardé."
Alors c'est ce que j'étais
dit, alors j'ai commencé à courir
aller du côté de la
étape pour obtenir l'ambulance.
Et pendant que je cours là-bas, j'y arrive
et il n'y a pas de conducteur, situation typique.
Je crie pour le chauffeur,
et je cours là-bas.
Où est le chauffeur du
ambulance, pour le leur chercher.
Et un flic dit hé, attendez, attendez.
Êtes-vous à propos de ce type qui a été poignardé?
J'ai dit oui, il a dit toi
pas besoin de courir, il est mort.
Et c'était comme un boyau, ça
était tellement mauvais à l'époque.
Et bien que le
les images n'ont jamais été diffusées
dans Les frères Maysles
film "Donne-moi un abri",
dans les années suivant l'événement,
témoignages
a rapporté que le corps de Hunter
a été porté sur scène
par les membres du public
dans une tentative de mettre fin à la violence des anges.
J'ai parlé aux gars qui ont porté son corps
sur scène, et j'ai parlé
au gars qui a porté
son corps depuis les coulisses de la scène.
Et ils l'ont mis
la scène, juste en face
de Keith Richards et des Hell's Angels
envahi et juste repoussé.
Il y a une photo de ça.
Il y a une photo de
Mick Jagger regarde au loin
avec sa main sur son
visage comme ça, et un tas de
Les Hell's Angels se sont penchés
mystérieusement dans le coin.
Ouais ils ont juste laissé tomber un cadavre
sur votre scène, et ils le repoussent.
Qu'est-ce que vous allez faire à propos de ça les gars ?
Ils vont rester
scène encore une heure...
terrifié.
J'ai chuchoté à Mick,
"le gars a été tué mec,
tu dois descendre de scène tout de suite", n'est-ce pas?.
"Il avait une arme à feu, tu dois quitter la scène"
à quoi Mick a répondu,
et bravo à l'homme,
et je l'ai toujours admiré pour cela.
"On ne peut pas quitter la scène, on ne peut pas partir"
"Nous devons terminer le spectacle."
Quand les pierres
finalement monté à bord d'un hélicoptère
et quittèrent Altamont, ils furent choqués par les obus.
En raison de prendre l'avion pour un certain nombre de
Spectacles européens le lendemain
leur emploi du temps ne permettait pas
leur temps de saisir pleinement
l'ampleur de l'événement
ils venaient de vivre.
Dans les jours qui suivirent,
où quelques reportages
passé sous silence la violence de la fête,
lentement, les faits ont commencé à émerger.
Et parallèlement aux arrestations
du chef de secte Charles Manson
et ses partisans meurtriers
quelques jours à l'avance,
bientôt Altamont a été identifié comme un
événement d'une réelle portée historique.
Eh bien, Altamont est toujours
la chose qui est citée
comme étant la fin du
l'ère du flower power, l'ère hippie.
Et je pense que c'est certainement un poteau indicateur.
Je pense que c'était en descente
tout le chemin après ça.
Le meurtre a tendance à
concentrer un peu l'esprit.
Je ne pense pas que les Stones
pris conscience de l'importance,
ou l'impact d'Altamont jusqu'à longtemps après.
Je pense que la plupart d'entre nous ne l'ont pas fait.
C'est le célèbre Zhou Enlai
chose quand, demandé vers 1950
sur l'impact des Français
Révolution sur la suite
cours de l'histoire, et il
dit qu'il était trop tôt pour le dire.
Donc, finalement, le genre
d'équivalent rock and roll
de ça en quelque sorte, personne
connu en décembre 69
ou même à l'été 1970 qu'il allait
entrer dans l'histoire du rock
comme ce moment séminal,
ce tournant, ce point de basculement.
Les dures vérités que ces événements représentent
à quel point le changement est difficile
est d'atteindre, et ce que
la violence dans la culture américaine représente,
et comment cela peut se manifester
même dans des contextes où
vous penseriez que ce serait
le dernier endroit où il se produirait,
ce sont des leçons importantes.
Et ce sont des leçons qui ont signalé,
devinez ce que nous ne sommes pas
retourner au Jardin.
Cela est devenu assez évident.
Je ne pense pas que quelqu'un se promenait
avec des fleurs dans les cheveux après tout ça.
Un nouvel équilibre a été trouvé, et en fait
très vite les gens ont presque pensé,
que s'est-il passé à la fin des années 60
alors, que s'est-il réellement passé ?
Le négatif est frappé
le bon là, malheureusement.
Et les gens voulaient
s'éloigner de cela.
Donc les années 70 il y avait
une sorte de pause marquée.
Les trucs de fleurs semblaient
juste une blague absolue.
J'ai vu Monétaire Pop en 1975,
et le public a ri,
ils ont ri au regard,
le son, tout.
J'étais horrifié par ça, c'est les années 60.
Pour moi, je me suis accroché
la bonne partie des années 60.
Il avait vraiment été mis au lit, cette période.
Les gens ne voulaient pas savoir, vous savez.
C'est devenu assez rapidement
la zone oubliée.
Et Altamont, et les meurtres de Manson
étaient instrumentaux,
vraiment, en fermant cette porte.
Et bien que les Stones aient bougé
toujours plus loin dans leur carrière,
l'événement a également fermé
la porte pour eux aussi.
Les mauvais garçons de l'invasion britannique seraient
ne plus jamais être au
centre de la culture,
politique et sociale
commentaire notamment absent de
leurs travaux ultérieurs,
ils règnent remarquablement
alors que la voix d'une génération s'était éteinte.
Il y a les Rolling Stones avant Altamont,
et il y a The Rolling
Pierres après Altamont.
Leurs juste deux choses distinctes.
Tout ce truc sur le
les gars noirs, et les mauvais garçons,
et la sympathie pour
le Diable avait joué
à cet exemple absolu et réel du mal.
Et ayant fait face à ça
qui ne pourrait jamais revenir en arrière
à leur petit royaume imaginaire.
Et vous pouvez le voir dans
l'album "Sticky Fingers".
Les trois chansons enregistrées avant Altamont,
"Cassonade", "Sauvage
Chevaux", et "Tu dois bouger"
sont des types de musique complètement différents
que le reste de cet album.
Quoi qu'il se soit passé à
Altamont aux Rolling Stones
cela les a changés pour toujours, et
leur musique n'a jamais été la même,
leurs spectacles n'étaient jamais les mêmes,
leurs relations personnelles
n'ont jamais été les mêmes,
rien sur leur vie
a continué comme avant.